AND HE CONTROLLED THE DRAWBACK
TO BYRAM ON
LEADING SCORER
AND GET BODIES TO THE NET AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE DOES
R
THE POINT RIGHT ON AND SAVE OT
ON T OUT THERE, CENTERING PASS.
PLAY.
AND VEGAS LEADS 2-
BEHIND THE NET, DOESN'T STAY
WITH SMITH
TRIES TO COUNTERATTACK  2:3636
TRYING TO GO AROUND JOHNSON WHO
POKED INTO THE QUANTA.
HE GOT
CHANCE I THINK THAT GOES OFF
CENTERED
AND HE WAS DENIED AT POINT-BLAN
BIG-TIME SAVE BUT MORE OF THAT
GOOD PUCK RETRIEVAL.
MUCH MORE MEAT AND POTATOES.
GREA
FROM RIGHT OUT IN FRONT OF
SLOPPY CLEAR ATTEMPT, KEPT IN
BY THEODORE, CENTERING PAST,
NOBODY T T
GET THERE FORECHECK GOING.
THIS IS THE LAST OPPORTUNITY
THROUGH A SCREEN THAT'S A FF TH.
AND THE AVALANCHE ARE ON THE
ON THE FACE-OFF OUT
HERE THOUGH, STOPPED AT POINT Y
THERE IS SOME ROOM NOW, ONE-ON-
ONE.
KE SURE YOU REMAIN PATIENT
BRAKE LIGHT
WAS IN A CHANGE.
THEY WERE TRYING TO FIND THDEFL
OUT IN FRONT, WENT JUST WIDE.
HE ALMOST HAD A WIDE EMPTY NET.
LOOKED LIKE HE HAD THE NET BUT
COULDN'T POKE IT IN. DEFENSEMEN
LOOKED LIKE IT WAS HAGUE TO GET
THE STICK ON BREAK OPPORTUNITY
HERE, MINUTES INTO
THE EVEN STRAIGHT, A SHORTHAND
GOAL.
HE SCORED FOR COLORADO.
VEGAS.
MAKING A 3-1 WITH 29.9 TO GO.